we've recorded
goodmorning believe nation today's
messages set your goals high over to you
Ted Turner my father told me when I was
a small boy did he strongly recommended
I set my goal so high that I couldn't
achieve in my lifetime because he had he
had set his goals
he said go after the depression that he
would be a millionaire and have a got in
a plantation and he had a small
plantation and he had a small yacht and
he was a millionaire and he couldn't
refocus its life and he said I made a
mistake doing that I'm having a lot of
trouble now because I've achieved by
goals and he said please set your goals
so high that you can't achieve them so
I'm trying to help save the world and I
think that's probably you know higher
than I buy I don't anticipate achieving
it completely but I would like to what
happens when you set a goal and then
achieve it a lot of times when you first
hit it you're excited right you're you
got the energetic I did it all that work
I finally hit my goal and then sadness
kicks in depression kicks in despair
kicks in you lose the motivation because
you don't know what you're shooting for
next and that happens especially when
the goal itself is hollow when it's not
about the process of achieving the goal
it's I'm doing all this work which sucks
because I want to achieve this goal and
if you didn't enjoy the work then the
next step is depression because you
don't know what to do next because your
work itself didn't have any meaning so
in terms of me I have a high goal I want
to help a billion entrepreneurs what
that does for me is help make sure that
the projects that I'm working on lead to
bigger results I don't know if I'll ever
hit a billion entrepreneurs the number
itself is irrelevant to me
there's no specific metric like this is
how I'm tracking it
and this is the only way that I'm gonna
really care if I hit my billion
entrepreneurs because I enjoy the
process of getting there because it
means that I need to do projects that
have the ability to hit millions of
people like my youtube channel like the
speaking engagements like the book deals
I need to do things that have big
potential appeal and not the smaller
stuff if I want to achieve my goal and I
enjoy the process of doing that work I
think it's good to have smaller goals
like I had a goal to have a hundred
thousand subscribers on my youtube
channel I was great I hit that woohoo
now it's to hit a million right I want
to hit a million YouTube subscribers and
I'm like three hundred fifty thousand
now and so whoo that's my next goal but
if that was the only goal right it's
like if the only reason I was doing
YouTube was because I wanted to hit a
million subscribers it would drastically
change the work that I'm doing it
there's a lot of stuff I could do on my
channel to get more subscribers faster
radical post more controversial stuff I
could post you know put in this person
against this person I could post a lot
of hate stuff and that will just
genuinely attract a lot more people a
lot more interest where I want to stay
more in the positive side I don't have a
lot of hate I don't have the negativity
I want to inspire people I want to push
people and because pushing people
requires work and is painful right to
change your mindset to change your
growth requires work it's not just gonna
happen by only watching one video not
taking any action they're not attract a
certain group of people who are ready
for that and it's a smaller audience but
that's who I want like that's the impact
that I want to have on you guys it's not
just chasing a hollow number of having a
million subscribers it's about the
impact it's the process that's making
videos that matter that means something
to me that means something to you where
you watch it and you want to go make a
difference and change your business
change your life change your community
change the people around you make a
positive contribution like that matters
to me and the way to measure it could be
having a million subscribers that is
it's a nice goal to have but if the
process of reaching it that means
something to me where a lot of people
set goals I want to have this amount of
money I want to buy this car or you know
see this many countries or whatever it
is and because you don't enjoy the
process along the way you're doing stuff
that you hate just to get to that goal
then the goal feels like a let that once
you get there because you don't know
what you're gonna do next
you'd enjoy any other journey along the
way so set a high goal said something
that makes you come alive and enjoy the
work that you're doing to get there even
if you never get there because you like
the work and you're having an impact
so the question day today is what is
your big goal leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching and have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press out